all right hello um we're gonna
do a walk through
for level 36 and pepper panic saga
we have uh two statues in the middle of
the board they're hard to get at in the
beginning when you're first starting out
it's kind of hard to understand how
these work
so we thought we would do a narration
over our video to give you an idea of
the things that you should be thinking
about
when we start we know if you read the
guide you know that we want to explode
these two peppers right here
when we start out though we see that
there's not a lot of green peppers on
the board to grow this one
and there's not really that many
orange although orange is a little bit
better so what we're going to do first
is just move some
things around at the bottom and see what
happens
okay so
let's see we have
green and orange still
we have a decent move with orange here
try that
alright so now it's looking like
purple is is pretty big and we can move
this green one over and set the purple
on the spot
plus the oranges
aren't bad either so we just want to
blow up orange or purple right now
here we could do we could blow up this
but we're gonna it will use up three big
peppers at the time so this one's a
little bit better because when we blow
up this one it's gonna blow up this one
and get a bit of a chain reaction
and we're real lucky that well it moved
anyways but
and you can kind of see in that in that
example there how these these spots
underneath the statues can also
damage the statues but it's really hard
to
keep these peppers in place when you're
making matches below
all right so now we have red and purple
we don't have really either one of those
colors
readily available
so we'll just make some other big moves
and see how things fall into place
and when you first start playing this
game it's a little bit hard to think
about how
things fall and where they're going to
end up especially in a board where you
have obstructions because
things don't just fall in straight lines
one thing one thing you always want to
look for when you're playing in a
statues level is this kind of match
right here this one's going to send a
shockwave that's going to hit this
statue right away
so you always want to make these kind of
matches because they're much quicker
than growing the peppers and doing it
that way
and we got another one another chocolate
went up and hit that there
all right so now things change totally
we only need one more hit
and
it's
what uh what's gonna happen is this
purple peppers here now but it's not
gonna probably stay there until the end
so what i'm gonna try to do is just grow
peppers as fast as possible
so that i can
get some action happening on the board
it um i mean obviously it's ideal if we
could just simply grow purple peppers
because we know that'll happen but
watch what happens as we're
making matches it won't exactly stay
exact right where we want it to
i mean you can also use that to your
advantage because
right now as you can see we have
this green one that will fall in its
place if it moves
and we have some other green ones that
are grown so you just want to every time
you make a move you just want to pay
attention to how things change
and so now
now we got a yellow one over here we
have purple here and here
you so now you just really want to check
and see if you can get something that'll
um
get the statue to explode right away
oh here here we go
so now we have a shock wave that will
hit this green pepper
and when it does that it will explode
now it may move
um
but we have other green peppers on the
board that already explode too so this
is probably going to be your best match
and as i said it moved
and we got really close with that purple
one but you know it didn't work out
always look around to see if you have a
shock wave if you don't then
just try to make moves that'll grow as
many peppers as you can
okay so we still have purple over here
we got orange up here
our red in our
and yellow looked like they would be the
easiest ones to set up i'm going to
match these
here
this is going to actually drop this
purple one out but we'll see which one
falls into place
and now we're going to get it up here
with the orange one
so i hope you have i hope that helps you
see how you uh how you think your way
through you just um
this is one of those levels it's hard to
figure out at first but it's not really
hard to complete once you got the idea
like i said if you read the guide you
understand that what you're trying to do
but hopefully this video helps to show
you that you know you don't want to get
stuck only trying to grow those
but that's the ultimate goal
you really have to uh just
you know reevaluate after each
move so i hope this was helpful um
if you have any questions leave a
comment and we get back right away
please take a second to like us on
facebook so that you can get our
updates in your feed and
we have lots of new stuff coming out all
the time so we look to look forward to
seeing you soon and helping you out as
much as we can